Happy's humble burger barn Happy's
humble burger barn any likeness is
purely coincidental ah
Happy's humble burger barn happy sambal
burger barn Happy's humble burger barn
Happy's humble burger barn Happy's
humble burger barn Happy's humble burger
barn Happy's humble burger barn
boink yay Jesus Christmas
what is happening how did I get here I
can spin my head 360 drive to work and
park on the side oh all right sure sure
sure sure
that musics loud alright where are what
happened to that bus oh if you know I
whoa whoa wait what I've seen many
driving intro sequences I've never had
one where I actually drive and this road
is a bumping alright oh my goodness Oh
park on the side Oh yogi ok arced nailed
it captain you don't need to worry about
me
I've got it parked better than you ever
believe boss boss boss Oh
grab your timecard and clock in this
reminds me of that Japanese convenience
store game I got happy sambal burger
barn employees only all employees must
clock in upon entering premises happy
humble burger barn and affiliates accept
no responsibility or liability upon
accident injury or even death only
employees and/or parties given prior
consent are able to enter the premises
from this door patrons man are on the
other side of the building thank you for
your cooperation
happy songul Berger Barnes mochas I've
combined my abilities here hmm
follow instructions displayed on the top
right the top right of what slap the
base
Oh
[Laughter]
no-one's ever slapped like I'm slapping
right now oh I gotta hold it down
alright well that was fun
heute [ __ ] those are some cute [ __ ]
I you know you're gonna write what about
the Saudi I don't find that whoa that is
a time card all right boom box do
nothing
I'm Clark telephone I did it I did the
thing interact with objects around
environment oh my it's beautiful in here
that roof needs a little work
very crooked oh my goodness
chilled patties onions tomatoes pickles
lettuce what happy the humble heifer
looks like a cow from kung pow enter the
fist all right well I'm already
disconcerted this seems old employee
notice all employees must wash hands
before returning to work well there's
not exactly a toilet well I don't think
I'm gonna have any trouble with that how
to make a Happy's deluxe grab a frozen
patty from the freezer and throw it on
the grill place it bought and lettuce
tomato onion pickles on the assembly
board please to cook patty on the
assembly board watches the burger
magically constructs itself serve it to
the customer with a big Happy's humble
smile here's my humble smile you ready
for it it's coming it's almost here
you're gonna love it
there it was hope you enjoyed it thank
you so much for being who you are those
don't look like salmon look it's YUM
strawberry jacuzzi I thought that's
Italy cold beverages icicle marriages
whoa I guess there's a Berkshire
[Music]
let's call that cow well I suppose I
have to go turn on the open side it's
not wet anymore open her up open for
business
open for bidding is open open for
business okay fine I should stop digging
around let's just do what it tells me to
do hate it hate that Oh manage customers
that come in well I don't see nobody so
I'm assuming there's no butter heel is
it it's like the Sun never gonna come up
or do I just constantly work at the
darkest dark oh oh yeah oh oh hey hi
how's it going you on a big hat for
smile huh I'll go the extra half a mile
you know what I'm saying yeah come on up
here you're horrible Oh God
salmon nuggets you got it all right one
order of salmon Doug's coming up if you
want your salmon nugs there you go
that'll be 225 think you take that
within there all right shake you got it
buddy boo there's a happy heifer shake
good job thank you did you pay do you
want more salmon nugs yep there you go
congratulations thank you wasn't there
someone else that just came in didn't I
see that someone else came in didn't I
see someone else came in low five hip
hop Street I mean it's a pretty good
stream hey welcome to the happy after
humble ombré burger store oh how oh your
eye your eyes horrible soft drink you
got it baby
all right you got it soft drink Happy's
deluxe all right so soft drink here's
your drink holy string serves it easier
there's my smile you want a happy heaven
Oh horrible horrible
everything's getting delivered with a
happy after smile maybe I should cook a
few more patties eh
I don't know should I okay Kedavra I
mean like they'll be a little old but
you know happy effort is about
efficiency
well that's sir ma'am oh there we go
alright food prep board am okay okay
okay
[ __ ] okay alright that's not good okay
oh my other one ah maybe this wasn't
such a good idea
okay uh pickles did is that oh my my
onion oh oh it took it
this is a double oh it's a double deluxe
cow what have I done
damn it dagnabbit dang do bit dang ding
alright whatever so far so good I mean
it seems really net wasn't there a
burger right there really I'm gonna do
these one at times a real [ __ ] and a
half hi hi diddly ho hey handsome
beautiful table dream shake happy lucky
you got it alright don't want this to
burn all right here's your Happy's
deluxe say here you go sand soft drink
that's it's like I'm really working at a
fast food restaurant eh there you go
take all the trash out of the kitchen I
didn't know you had any I guess we got
trash GoGet take it out the back
sure sure sure sure sure
oops I can't throw very far whoa [ __ ]
baby don't know it sounds like I'm
shooting it anybody else coming in oh I
was a customer ah I got time I got time
I got time I got that Top Trumps
hey how's it going happy happy happy
okay salmon nugs two orders of salmon
Doug's coming right up thank you
really weird I mean I bet salmon snow
gets would face pretty good to be
perfectly honest you know no whoa hi
happy the humble heifer
all right Happy's humble heifer heifer
hi happy investigate the noise wait that
was actually a noise I thought that was
just random [ __ ] that you were
pulling on me
[Applause]
[Music]
hello hello hello hello this is turn
that off for a second oh there's a
drive-through oh I see
oh all good now everything is a-okay
perfectly fine here that was normal that
was greatly normal that's that's fun
hi you might not want to be here it's
first place of death hey also it's
self-serve drink why am I have to get
you drink hey how's your eyeball great
good salmon Doug's fries Happy's deluxe
you got it baby
all right you go Sam nuggets oh I gotta
make fries god damn it don't I I bet I
do I have to pop fries nope fries all
right you're Happy's Luck's gonna take a
minute we make them fret here we make
them fresh never frozen only chilled so
don't you worry about a thing I'll get
you your fresh burger you'll watch me
make it you're gonna look me right with
your stupid stinky eye and a half
transparent face as I make it hold on
hold on oh you're so beautiful from this
distance your features are so polygonal
uh-huh glad I don't have to stare at you
anymore
here you go gobble this down they have a
happy every day in every happy half away
okay bye see ya you could close the
other door to amuse your pan aye
[Music]
oh that's it Oh making it easy on me
come on
[Music]
okay all right I'll check the speaker
outside yeah it seems pretty good I
don't what a call your boss in the
office phone also what happened a
customer that was just there there was a
customer people gonna drive if that's in
the way
[Applause]
[Music]
Sol saw his cow so Kogi is beef okay Oh
God right it's looked good
also what happened to the half the raw
wood there was a road that went in here
at one point in time what's going on
over here oh hey
the humble happy effort is that gone
over there
oh is it gone it's gone isn't it oh no
you're not going okay never mind I
thought you were gone
lovely music really a bob I like it a
lot
gotta turn it right off hey boss there's
a bit of a problem heard a bit from
bloom hey boss you ever have an
experience where like the whole
nightmare of a place comes alive and I
feel like I'm gonna die never get that
boss trouble hi boss boss please you got
to believe me I would never cause
trouble
I'm your best employee hope you stop
Hoople you're my mr. Miyagi
I'm your whatever the guys name was Kahn
I'm Han you gotta believe me just I'm
just honking fries it's all I ever do
it's all you ever taught me to do Hakan
Huck off the fries the Berg's the shakes
the slammin humble shakes you Buckley's
son of a [ __ ] why is your head so
jiggly all right shake shake Oh shake
shake yeah sure
was it my burger my burgers gonna burn
BLAP got one of those ready
all right let's pop that right there
just in case someone wants a piece of
the looks I've completely forgotten all
about my troubles so you know who needs
to worry about haunted cows it's nothing
it's great love this cheap high also say
oh come on in
are you I'm suddenly duh Happy's deluxe
you are in luck freshly made you want to
talk about fresh stuff that in your gob
well it's my time and I would rather I
shouldn't come to you Doug Lee son of a
[ __ ] hooba hooba hooba
ohoo ohoo me are you Anson devil here we
go no mama whoa hey okay here I go
Oh into the other world
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you tipos in me you son-of-a-bitch
I need a cigarette Oh take away the
cigarettes Oh No
oh hey happy ever this is weird
oh wow oh wow oh wow this facility has
been condemned it is no longer safe for
any and all living things to any and all
access beyond this point will be
considered just passing there is nothing
beyond this point worth dying for
Paragon genetic technology Paragon
security systems I'm sorry
[Music]
Oh
oh hi are you those handsome bevels I've
heard so much about oh I bet this is
messed up this is so messed up this is
so weird
Oh what is happening to them what is
happening them what's happening to you
what kind of minecraft villager are you
what's going on with your face and body
what's happening to you are you
metamorphosizing oh what's wrong with
your face oh nothing's wrong with your
face that's just the way it's always
been
right except that it moves and you move
and tonight technology wing 13 in the
event of an emergency follow the
evacuation protocol the entire facility
has been marked with path indicators on
the floor as depicted below remain calm
and leave in an orderly fashion
I'm sorry what is this for why is this
why would you do this what is what is I
don't understand why oh happy heifer had
seen better days
it's dork very dork very dork it's dork
dork and narrow door narrow and dork
dork and narrow is nothing here
oh there's something here Wade slave
simulation scenario wool
living paycheck-to-paycheck audio-visual
brain under and trained mint
trauma-based climax light drugging what
maple overlook hospital nurse aid
continual trauma medium drugging legacy
lawn burial grounds gravedigger visual
brain and Trainmen theatrical trauma
heavy drugging seven banners theme park
ride operator forced trauma peripheral
trauma why that seemed fun about to give
my longest hello baby you've ever seen
hello alright cool bye I love you
son I'm hey hi not as much no not as
visceral reaction there are you mister
paragon just a paragon of virtue the
cheese maze initiative okay in this
series of experiments we will attempt to
influence or control the minds of our
test subjects through themed auditory
and visual cues these cues will be
intensified to a dramatic conclusion at
which time the subjects should
theoretically be under our complete
control whenever they are subjected to a
trigger test subjects who managed to
break their conditioning tend to panic
into a fight-or-flight response we
observe this behavior and only 0.5% of
our test subjects of that 0.5% a rare
one in a hundred shut down completely
even rare one 500 got violent how many
tests did you run they were disposed of
accordingly
each test subject is placed in a
customized scenario subjected to several
cycles of therapy and programming the
therapy programming normalizes the
scenario and embeds deep mental triggers
when a subject is released back into the
wild they can now be triggered into a
subservient State the goal of this
experiment is to discover a means of
indefinite hypnotic control and/or
influence over desires subjects a
constant state of hypnosis is not a
desirable outcome a so called sleeper
state of hypnosis that can be active
via verbal audio or visual cues is ideal
triggers can include a frequency
admitted through radios or cellular
devices or images broadcast on
television computer screens once
subjects have been triggered
theoretically handlers can then assume
control of and direct the subjects
herding the sheep as dr. Grimm himself
putted munis honest all right cool so
I've I hey have I been hypnosis am I
currently under the Hypnose Susie's Oh
operation eagle eye subliminal messages
and suggestions can be caught by the
subconscious in some scenarios we will
test both the direct hypnosis state
trigger potential of visual cues to the
individual but also gather data on
society-wide indoctrination via
subliminal suggestion to speak bluntly
if we can brainwash people to buy more
Paragon products we can fund more
experiments consumerist influencing is
very much a side goal of dr. grim and an
important one at bat and enables us to
engineer society rigor for a regular
menu and subliminal menu right the
regular menu is this your standard menu
from every happy humbles burger bar
location the subliminal menu has dual
purpose in this experiment the raw meat
mac runs on the menu are meant to
specifically inspire disgust and unease
his feeds into the trauma training
aspect of our h hbb scenario however we
are also testing the effects this menu
has on the subject upon release back
into society will they frequent happy
humbles locations despite the dormant
trauma will they remember their first
time flipping burgers when they find
themselves on the other side of the
counter will it cause them to fall into
a hypnotized state or will it cause them
to panic there's much to learn oh so
much to learn knowledge science more
testing is required
sounds like Oh what's his name from
portal 2 I can't even remember oh my
urgent see action notification I'm ready
to receive the note approximately three
hours after sunrise an accident and a
military facility located at the act
house location resulted in a nuclear
explosion find shelter immediately fill
empty bottles and buckets with water
remain calm and stay in your homes
protect yourselves in your family
okay be prepared to ration food and
water for a period of up to 15 days all
the nations of the world have begun
pooling resources to overcome this great
Cataclysm together size viens across the
world stay strong I'm sorry what's a
Savion what's a sybian a sky Vianne a
sky thigh in what's the sky fie an
sahabat is under a nationwide curfew do
not leave your homes until further
notice
sahabat the Sabbat governments is in
talks with all nations of safe seith a
united front has been established to
contain the fallout what is happening
this broadcast will now end bright thank
you can I go back to the statue that's
what I want thank you all right see you
around
oh my god I get happen what
I gotta get a heifer heck on out of here
oh hello Oh
operation songbird auditory brainwave
entrainment alpha state is relaxed theta
stays offers stress relief Delta
encourages relaxation gamma waves
fastest brainwave frequency interesting
is it doing it to me is it currently
doing the binaural beats
[Music]
it's still you are destroyed you won't
destroy me get away from me why's got to
get out of here we gotta get out of here
I gotta get out of here hello oh my oh
my hi um well I mean I guess bye
okay yeah uh yeah tape sure sha sha sha
sha sha sha sha sure sure sure sure
sha sha sha sha sha hello
[Music]
the consequences for our supers the
consciousness of innocent people and
sick experiments forged of
indoctrination psychological slavery I
can't live with myself any longer but
before I shed this existence for the
next I must blow the whistle on the
inhumane and cruel practices happening
at this and all other outcast Island
research facilities I've shipped this
video and massive data packages to every
media outlet I could find from the
Sabbat Broadcasting Company to Maverick
Cooper whoa expose the file underbelly
of Paragon dr. Thorne was once a good
man
but he has lost his mind
surely I've lost mine as well we cannot
cheer death but you're not even sure her
on avarice and vanity and we surely
cannot stop what's coming
Oh oh wow okay so that was a happy
humble burger shop that was a wild ride
from start to finish that went places
that I didn't think it was gonna go and
then it took other turns that I didn't
think it was gonna need but good
I gotta admit good it was very scary in
the beginning at least it was very very
scary and then took this real turn which
was good to be perfectly honest I don't
know why things were going nuts in the
burger shop I was kind of more into that
anyway I expected the game to end like
when the last scare happened just be
like one of those like ah you know it's
just a random horror game but no it was
it was like oh we got a message we're
going to say it so and I can't fault it
for that thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to play this for
yourself I'll put a look at the
description below apparently the
developer has other games maybe they're
as cerebral more cerebral not as
cerebral as this one I have no idea so
just thank you everybody so much for
watching check out more scary games that
I've done in the description or the
suggested videos subscribe willing to
bail to know when more scary games are
gonna come in and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]